probably the fastest
I'm talking about the parent back in the
US to start with actually
the fastest passage from sort of Health
to death really since bearings actually
so I mean bearings as you'll remember
um you know was a sort of Friday to
Sunday thing and this was pretty similar
so yes I mean I would if you don't mind
draw a distinction with credit Suite
which we might come on to which is
actually much more drawn out to fair but
yes it was a very fast passage to uh to
failure so you mentioned uh Credit
Suisse uh their governor and uh
obviously quite a few of banking stocks
Regional banks in the US we've heard in
recent days pressure on the share price
of Deutsche Bank and so on
um You probably won't want to comment on
areas outside the UK but I just wondered
uh whether you think today that these
individual idiosyncratic events are on
our past and that things have settled
down and this terminal in the banking
sector in March is behind us well we've
we've sent you an assessment of the UK
banking sector and obviously we'll be
very happy to discuss any points you
want to discuss out of that I think
the U.S authorities are still dealing
with you know some of the consequences
of the uh the issue in the regional
banks that manifested itself in Silicon
Valley Bank
I Think Credit Suisse I would say well
obviously as you say come on to happy to
talk about that
um is a rather institutional specific
story about long-run issues uh in the
institution so my view and I'm certainly
I'm a very strong view with the UK
banking system is that it is in a strong
position uh both capital and liquidity
wise it is not showing signs of uh of
problems in that respect and we test it
as you know very extensively
I also think that what we saw at the
tail end of last week Friday in
particular when yeah there were there
were uh quite sharp Market movements you
know I think I think there are moves and
markets to if you like test out firms I
would not want to say that those in my
estimation are based on identified
weaknesses more than testing out I mean
there is quite a bit of testing out
going on at the moment I think
last September
of driven invest testing which was way
outside the parameters of any stress
test that you had run some have any of
these developments been outside the
stress tests of the sorts of things that
you model for well I make a distinction
here between the capital treatment of
interest rate risk which was a relevant
factor in the demise of the parent Bank
Silicon Valley
we do capitalize that risk very
thoroughly for UK Banks including by the
way for Silicon Valley Bank UK and you
know I'm entirely content of the
stresses we've seen are inside the types
of stresses that we apply for Capital
purposes where I think there might be
more of a policy question it's an
international question in which we'll
take close interest is around the
calibration of the liquidity coverage
ratio so that's the sort of one month
liquidity if you like the banks have to
hold and
um as Andrew was just mentioning
a very striking feature of the Silicon
Valley Bank Run not so much of the
credit series one by the way was just
the speed with which it took place and I
think there's a table in Andrew's letter
quite helpful what you can see is
basically three billion deposits or 2.9
going out in a day on Friday the 9th of
March um the sort of outflow rates that
we have so the percentage of deposits
that are assumed to run out in their LCR
ratio some actually are 100 so deposits
from financial institutions are assumed
all to go but operational deposits are
less than that and Retail deposits
they're still so I think there's going
to be a question for all of us as to
whether but it is a question I emphasize
whether those outflow rates are quite
High Enough
well I think
um it's much easier now isn't it to move
your deposits electronically you don't
have to queue round the block to take
your money out of a particular Bank you
can move it within seconds and so
presumably you will have to think about
what it is that you stress test for when
you're looking at some of these rules
yeah I think I think that's right I mean
all of us can move money you know from
our accounts in a short time and it's
taken me to answer this question as you
say and that is a relatively new feature
of the market the other aspect that
we've had and we have dealt with by the
way in various situations in the past
but it's more prominent is the speed
with which news can travel particularly
among communities and sometimes sort of
uh through through private messaging
groups that is a noticeable film on both
here and elsewhere I do think that in
this case you also had an issue that you
asked about in your letter which was the
concentrated nature of the deposit base
of this particular firm I think that was
an exacerbating Factor but we're going
to have to look at all that for sure and
and um
governor in terms of
um the events of March I'm not sure that
I heard a clear sort of yes no answer to
my question about were these some
pressures at idiosyncratic cases around
the world it was is this something more
systemic and would you be able to say
today as we end near the end of March
that this turmoil is behind us
well I think there is a story in the
Silicon Valley Bank U.S case which I
think we will come on to I'm sure which
is to do with the treatment of it what
we call interest rate risk in the
banking book so this is not trading
activity this is interest rate was in
the bank
we treat that differently in our Capital
ratio which I think we set out in the in
the paper we sent you and I'm happy to
it would be happy to go through that
um we treat it differently to the US
um and that is an important difference I
think there is an issue there
um because of course that obviously goes
back
that is an issue but it's not I think an
issue in in the UK because we do treat
it differently and that obviously
relates to the question of the you know
of the rise in interest rates and how
much and how quickly
I think there's a lot that was there was
a lot that was idiosyncratic about
Credit Suisse
um uh which we
will say a bit about but obviously it's
not one of ours as a parent now
to your question I don't think that any
of them when we've said this that any of
these you know features cause you know
stress in the UK banking system but the
definitive yes no answer your question
goes back to what you said about the
markets last week they are trying on to
find points of weakness at the moment
now I don't think we are at all in the
place we were in in 20078 so we're a
very different place to then but yeah we
have to be very Vigilant so you know if
I give you the answer I don't think
there's a problem going forward I do not
want to give you for a moment the idea
that we are not very Vigilant because we
are we are in a period of very
heightened you know frankly tension and
alertness and we will go on being good
yeah so anyway that's the that's the
message I'd really like to give you if
you don't mind in answering that
question okay thank you um
yeah thanks chair all I wanted to really
do was was illustrate the point Andrew
was making about the wider context I
mean when you think of what's going on
in Global Financial markets at the
moment I mean the U.S treasury market
one of the most liquid in the world
implied volatility last week close to
post Global financial crisis highs so
you've got the the recent
events in these particular banks that
have you know the markets have responded
to and as Andrew says are testing but
that that also plays into a longer term
picture you know we've all appeared
before you to talk about the ldi episode
last Autumn where you've seen these
events
you know off the scale moves in markets
triggering
um uh responses so I think we this is
why we have to remain incredibly
Vigilant looking for good morning it's
10 o'clock you're watching Sky News and
this is Ian King live in our business
and it's economic news from the Heart of
the City well before we get to our
guests this morning we're currently
listening in to the treasury select
committee where the governor of the bank
of England Andrew Bailey is giving
evidence to MPS over the collapse and
rescue of Silicon Valley Bank we'll have
a listen to other risk factors but we
you know we have to remain incredibly
Vigilant I I I would just note that in
terms of the Government Bond markets you
mentioned U.S treasuries you know two of
the big buyers which were the Federal
Reserve Bank and
China probably not buying as much as as
before and so I I do accept that you'll
need to be vigilant on those risks
um Anthony thank you chair
um so my questions are really going to
focus on
whether Silicon Valley Bank was prepared
or not or how well prepared so on
Thursday the 9th of March I think I'm
right in saying that if your assessment
of Silicon Valley Bank would be that it
met all the regulatory requirements yeah
UK Silicon Valley Bank UK uh it met all
the regulation requirements you've
expected of it it was uh well
capitalized it had the right liquidity
coverage ratio it was closely supervised
by you you had the information you
needed about it and yeah it collapsed
the following day doesn't that suggest
that your supervisory regime and
criteria simply aren't fit for purpose
well let me start I'm sure you know
someone wants to come in
keep on to make two coupons for you to
start with
no subsidiary
can be expected to survive the failure
of its parent I don't think that is a
reasonable expectation I mean they're
too tightly Associated and connected to
to do that so
foreign
I would not work on the basis of that
expectation now by the way one of the I
think the key things that was done and
it was done last summer we took about
two years to do was that Silicon Valley
Bank UK was a branch until then now it
it passed through the point in our
policy where there's a level of fscs
protected deposits and if they if a
branch goes a foreign Branch goes above
that level when we say that you need to
subsidiarize and it did that and I want
to stress that because had it not done
that had we still had a branch on our
hands it would have been altogether much
more difficult situation so that's
important we it was sub-sidroized
the point I want to make you said you
know I said in response to you well no
subsidiary Will Survive the failure of
its parent but that's not the end of the
story because what we had I think on our
hands was a well-capitalized subsidiary
and it had strong liquidity as Sam's
just said it you know it lost about 30
percent of its deposits in one day but
it did have the cash cash buffers to to
meet those to meet those outflows
now that's important because what it
meant is that going into the weekend
we were working with a bank
that you know there was a reasonable
prospect that we could do something to
to resolve it which would come out on
the other side as it did with a purchase
frankly if the bank's not sold them
going into the weekend that that becomes
you know immeasurably harder so so I
would emphasize I don't think you can
expect subsidiary we should not work on
the assumption that subsidiaries or
survive the failure of their parents but
what we must do is have the subsidiary
in a you know in a good state so that
when we then turn to resolution we can
do something with it
I think the team did a very good job of
making sure that the UK subsidiary was
capitalized including concentration risk
um and on interest rate risk um but back
to your your original question there is
a bit of a trade-off in these things we
could remove run risk from banks by
requiring 100 outflow of all deposits to
be held in reserves at the bank of
England
um but we're choosing not to do that we
do not want to operate a zero Federal
regime because there will be some
significant costs in terms of
availability of lending to the economy
and that's the trade-off that is made in
all regulations having said that I won't
repeat what I said earlier but I do
think we've got to look back at these
outflow rates in the LCR specifically
and say what have we learned from this
also in due course what have they
learned from the other banks in the
states that we're not involved with
speaking the head of the Prudential
regulation Authority if you want to
continue following the treasury select
committee you can scan the QR code which
is about to come up on the side of your
screen right now to be confident uh that
it really was helpful